(audience clapping)
- Do either one of you know Nick Offerman?
- [Celebrity] Not personally.
- I have known Nick
Offerman for a long time.
Megan Mullally is one of
my dear friends, his wife.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- We did the revival of
Greece together back in 1994.
- I love it.
- You know, so I've, I've
known them for a great...
- Such a great couple and I
love that he's so talented.
He's a man of many, many talents, y'all.
He's an actor, a comedian, an
author, and in the vein of one
of these things is not like the other.
He's a woodworker too.
He literally can build you like a canoe.
Like it's crazy.
Last week when we were in
rehearsals getting ready to
launch this new season, I was
surprised when Nick popped
up here on the stage looking
very dashing by the way.
And apparently he just wanted to make sure
that the studio was in tiptop
shape for our new season here
in New York, and he wanted
make sure it's safe,
so check this out.
(audience clapping)
(crew members chatting)
(guitar strumming)
- [Director] Practice the walk over here.
This is your first guest.
You'll come out, we just
gotta stand them coming in.
- Okay.
- All right everybody, standby.
- Woo.
- Here we go.
- Alright everybody.
Our first guest is the only person ever,
woman or man, to win the three big awards
for film, TV, and stage acting
in both the US and the UK.
Please give it up for dame Helen Mirren.
(upbeat show music)
(Kelly laughs)
- [Kelly] You look so handsome.
- Kelly, you look so beautiful.
- What are you doing here?
- I was just in the neighborhood.
Moving into a new home
is always difficult,
and I happened to be in the neighborhood
so I thought I'd stop by and offer Kelly
any I help that I possibly could.
- Do you like what we're
we've got going on?
- I do.
I see some walnut. I see some oak.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
Sturdy.
- Yeah.
- We gotta bought a box of games.
- Oh, it's my podium.
- I know.
We've still got the lectern of integrity.
- [Nick] And as I was looking
around the set, I noticed,
you know, gratifyingly,
that they had brought
my lectern of integrity with them.
Can you tell me why does it say Jonas?
- [Kelly] Well, here's the thing,
Nick Jonas came and, you know,
we wanted to make him just feel special.
Still yours.
- Is he still a furniture builder?
- No, I don't think so.
- Oh.
- Huh.
- A musician named Nick
Jonas had added his name.
Might as well have been Judas.
There we go.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Nick] I've got some
sandpaper right here.
We call that an East Coast touch up.
- I like it.
- [Nick] I mean, you know,
the, the scuttlebutt is
that Joe Jonas is very nice,
but apparently Nick is
a real piece of (beep).
Well, I guess since we're here and...
- What's this?
- I'm actually in town promoting
the paperback release of my last book.
- Thank you.
- [Nick] To merth, heart,
Jonas can suck it.
- [Kelly] Suck it. (laughs)
(crew laughing)
I love it.
- That'll show him.
- I know.
- It's relatively well known that
I know my way around a toolbox.
So thought I'd sneak in and see
if they could use any help
with my expertise in scenery.
- [Director] So standby,
and just do a little reading here.
- Okay. Perfect.
- [Director] See how it's going, okay?
- Alright everybody
so our first guest is the only person ever
woman or man to win the
three big awards for
film, TV, and stage acting
in both the US and the UK.
(tape measure rattling)
What's going on?
Is it pretty good or?
- [Nick] I've been known
to be handy with a hammer
or a tape measure or roll of drywall tape.
Is that just for rehearsal or
is this table gonna stay here?
- You know, I think it might be staying.
- Alright. You might want to
you might wanna replenish the finish.
- Oh.
- [Nick] And it looks
cool, but you don't wanna
spill gravy in it.
- Okay, well I don't wanna spill
gravy, I just wanna eat it.
I don't wanna spill any of it.
- There's one place to
spill gravy, am I right?
In the gravy hole.
- Alright everybody, we
always like to close out
with something trending online,
so this is what I'm liking.
Hey, what's up Nick?
- Oh hey, sorry.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Don't worry about me.
We're just finishing up some final tweaks.
Do you know who did this tuck pointing?
- I, you know what?
I don't even know what you
said if I'm being honest.
- All right.
- Okay. Alright, well you keep doing you.
- [Nick] Alright.
- Thank you.
- The risers at first glance
are solid, but the pine
that they used for the structure
is a little bit naughty
and eventually that's
gonna need reinforcement,
but for now, it should be fine.
The coffin locks that
they're using to lock
in the platforms seem to
be like an aluminum alloy.
Yes, they're a little bit
cheaper, but come check with me
in three years and see if those
things are still operating.
The conniption rods won't
last you more than 18 months.
Hope I was able to help out a little bit.
I'm glad to be a good
neighbor whenever I can.
And best of luck to Kelly
with the new season.
I'm sure it's gonna be terrific.
Can't wait to come back.
(door handle rattles)
Piece of (beep).
(door unlocking)
I got it.
(audience cheering)
- One more time, y'all.
Give it up Nick Offerman.
- Woo.
- [Kelly] Love him so much.
His book, Where the Deer and Antelope Play
is now available in paperback,
and it will be on permanent
display on my set because I love him.
Alright, so you can also see Nick
on his US comedy tour right now.
He's hilarious. Go see him.
You'll feel good about yourself.
Go online for tickets
if you wanna go see it.